est ce que eric zemmour on va déclarer
sa candidature bientôt tous les
journalistes se pose cette question là
tous les français tremble etc on se
demande s'il va être candidat non pas du
tout heureusement pas s'il est reconduit
dans ses colonies là encore en revanche
ce qu'on ne sait pas et que je pense
rond qu'on peut essayer d'expliquer
c'est que sa candidature il va pas la
déclarer maintenant tout le monde le
pouce avec art et maintenant parce que
voudrait que ce soit éclaircie tout ne
parle du 9 novembre qui serait le jour
de la mort du général de gaulle à
colombey les deux églises si a priori
dans les équipes zemmour ils savent pas
encore exactement comment ça se passe et
ils se disent que c'est le plus tard
possible qu'il faut qu'il annonce sa
candidature parce que manuel macro
lui-même ne l'annoncera sans doute pas
avant février et que je pense qu'il ya
un an mais un côté chez les ch et les
zemmouris sts d'imaginer que leur
candidat est à peu près l'équivalent des
manuels macro et quoi qu'il faut qu'il
se calme aussi ma peau sur lui que ce
modèle en ce début de campagne de
zemmour c'est un décalque de ce café
mène au micro-ondes en 2016 2017 c'est
la différence que c'est un des quelques
subi c'est-à-dire qu'ils ont été lancés
en pré campagne malgré eux c'est par des
sorties dans la presse qui les ont
forcés à se découvrir alors que eric
zemmour imaginer après la sortie de son
livre faire un tour de france d'accord
pour aller faire des dédicaces mais sans
qu'on que bruissent partout le fait
qu'ils seraient candidats et donc pour
l'instant ils subissent plutôt la chose
et ils ont intérêt d'après eux à
repousser le plus loin possible cette
annonce de candidature parce que de
toute façon d'arrêter des français il
est déjà candidat et que cette
candidature n'aura pas d'effet
stupéfiants chez les gens qu il va
l'annoncer mais en revanche va le placer
comme candidat c'est-à-dire devoir se
plier à toutes les règles de base de la
démocratie de telles qu'elles sont pour
l'élection présidentielle et pour
l'instant il préfère continuer de servir
sow servi dans les comptes de campagne
enfin tout ce qu'il fait aujourd'hui
déjà comptabilisés comment ça se passe
parce qu'il a un qg de campagne ce tour
de france est déjà une campagne on le
voit qu'il remplit des salles et
derrière puis va se déclarer tard plus
il tord les règles c'est un oui mais
pour les candidats qui eux sont déjà
déclarés déclaré sa candidature
aujourd'hui ça voudrait répondre à des
questions comme quel est votre entourage
quel est votre équipe de campagne sauf
qu'elle est quelle partie vous avez
quartier qui vous allez présenter aux
législatives qui vous suit et je pense
que pour l'instant ils sont pas encore
arrivés à construire ça totalement
[Musique]